chi lo sa se parlerò della bellezza
forse no
vi racconterò una storia c'era una volta
un paese meraviglioso più bel paese del
mondo quel paese c'è ancora naturalmente
del nostro tutto contornato dalle alpi
con delle pianure stupende sotto le alpi
e poi convincendo le colline e poi
cominciano gli appennini e poi se arrivi
in fondo con quel triangolo fantastico
in questo paese che tutti hanno sempre
voluto dai celti annibale tutti ho
voluto l'italia va bene in questo paese
naturalmente abitavano tante persone
abitavano dai tempi e dai tempi antichi
però una volta paese pericoloso e quindi
la gente
abitava in poche città e in tanti paesi
ma questa città e questi paesi erano
tutti in contornati da mula perché
perché vuole la pericoloso fuori c'erano
i boschi e c'erano i lupi i briganti per
quella gente si si si raccoglieva
intorno e viveva in questi piccoli paesi
costruiva delle mura che li difendessero
il muro non potevano essere enormi
perché costruire delle mura costa un
sacco di soldi mantenerle anche poi per
insegnarle pure e quindi all'interno i
paesi e non abbastanza piccoli e le
strade erano strette fra una casa e
l'altra le case avevano poca aria perché
non c'era tanto spazio però c'erano
anche delle belle piazze all'interno
erano nella mente dei formicai e sulle
piazze dava la chiesa nelle piazze ci si
trovava la piazza era un po lavorano era
un po dove come con i greci greci si
trovavano a chiacchierare e poi c'è la
chiesa ripeto c'erano le grandi
processioni oggi prima di noi ci sono
più una volta ci danno un sacco di preti
e quindi uscivano che baldacchini e poi
tutti chirichetti e anche e anche quelli
che magari non ci credevano tanto
andavano anche loro anche i briganti
andavano che poi briganti siano stufati
di vivere fuori e sono andate a vivere
anche loro nei paesi nei palazzi oggi
vivono in brasile importanti ma fatto
sta insomma questo paese è meraviglioso
fu quello voi nel 1338 ambrogio
lorenzetti di pisa sul muro del palazzo
pubblico di siena quella città
meravigliosa chiusa con tutte le porte
perché poi la mattina la mattina si
aprivano le porte alla gente andava in
queste campagne stupende coltivava le
viti le messe
era una vita straordinaria il paesaggio
l'uomo ha formato il paesaggio con le
sue mani il paesaggio italiano che oggi
noi ne abbiamo aperto un bobo ma c'è
ancora tanto di questo paesaggio
stupendo e poi però veniva buio punti
lupi briganti tutti tornavano nei loro
paesi si chiudevano le porte si stava
bene all'interno di questi paesi di
queste città si stava sicuri e ci si
conosceva tutti perché si rivede in poco
spazio e poi si aprivano le le osterie
si aprivano le bettole si avevano anche
le case chiuse a una volta c'erano
adesso non ci sono più
insomma è una vita che ambrogio
lorenzetti di pisa come il buon governo
poi vengono i signori vengono chieste
vennero i medici e vennero i farnese e
quindi forse era un po più di sicurezza
forse probabilmente forse i lupi a tutto
punto non c'erano più perché non c'era
neanche vf ancora che li proteggeva per
cui evidentemente non c'era più nemmeno
bisogno di chiudere le porte la sera e
poi con cera le grandi guerre le bombe
cadevano da cedono quindi non c'era più
nemmeno bisogno delle mura e quindi
tutto punto si comincia ad andare a
vivere fuori dalle mura e una casetta
qui una casetta li questo punto c'era un
ala baccano e il fabbro facevo un casino
di inferno e il falegname perde un sacco
di polvere quindi alla meglio che non sa
sono fuori delle mura ma che tanti
pericoli uguali dentro fuori e quindi e
poi lato per fortuna comunque poi
arrivarono anche i rea rivale di savoia
e arrivò il cielo anche il papato che
facevo tutto quello che non faceva
quello che dicevano francesco nocera ben
altro papato a suo tempo è insomma ha
fatto sta che però le condizioni di vita
migliorarono anche obiettivamente
italiani diventarono più ricchi e quindi
si comincia appunto quelli piccoli
fabbrichette il fabbro falegname si
ingrandiranno fuori delle mura è lecita
diventarono quindi nelle città ci fu
bisogno di più spazio e quindi le strade
strette felicità diventano dei grandi
viali dei grandi viali alberati
meravigliosi si costruisce dei giardini
pubblici stupendi grandi come il parco
sempione di milano come la video
comunale di napoli e poi delle grandi
piazze occorrono anche il principe è il
regime a tutti quelli più importanti del
mondo era molto bello mi viene da citare
i paesi
ovviamente c'erano un po meno soldi per
quei grandi diario da lati non ceramica
poi tanti e quindi cosa successe nei
paesi successe che la gente appunto
cominciò siccome non c'era tanto spazio
a uscire e quindi e poi pecco arrivarono
anche da grandi fabbriche naturalmente
quelle quindi arrivo le fabbriche che
comunque ostruiva tante macchine arrivo
alla favola che coi costumi costruiva
tante gomme e quindi costruire delle
grandi case per tutti gli operai che
venivano anche da sud per per far
mandare avanti queste fabbriche è però
la gente cominciò dicevo prima a stare
meglio nelle case gironi bagni la scuola
diventa obbligatoria napoli sindacati
che tutti insomma e gli ospedali
la società obiettivamente insomma tutti
noi vi diamo meglio di come si viveva
nel medioevo su questo non ci piove però
certamente certamente cosa è successo
certamente è successo che tutti i paesi
tutti i mille paesi sono 7 mila in
italia forse non tutti ma la stragrande
maggioranza e cominciarono a perdere
significato perché i figli di chi stava
nei paesi erano abbastanza ricchi quindi
cominciamo a fare un po di soldi e
quindi costruirlo un figlio una villetta
un altro figlio un'altra la figlia
invece andò abitare col figlio di
un'altra famiglia caso rapporto della
diletta i nonni continuavano a vivere il
paese anche genitore ma quando morirono
i nonni quando voluto i genitori di
quelle case in paese non lego le più
nessuno perché le nuove case avevano il
garage della macchina avevano un piccolo
giardino magari con la piccola
piscinetta chi lo sa quindi sono
obiettivamente la più gradevole e poi
cosa vuoi una volta i negozi erano tutti
nei paesi però una volta andava a piedi
o in bicicletta ma perché andare a piedi
in bicicletta che l'associazione
macchine però una volta genera 6 centro
poi venne 1100 poi venne la prima o poi
vengono i suv perché oggi tutti a non
avere i sum e quindi non c'è mica posto
nei paesi per andare a fare la spesa col
suv e quindi i negozi si trasferirono
fuori da vicino alle case dove le strade
sono più grandi le provinciali e quindi
la farmacia il macellaio la cartoleria e
la merceria chiuso tutti e quindi
nessuno aveva più bisogno di andare in
paese perché era tutto fuori per fortuna
in paese c'era la chiesa perché
costruire delle chiese così belle come
quelle che c'era una volta costa un
sacco
soldi e quindi è però in chiesa
la gente ci va mica tanto oggi si diceva
per la comunione non si sposta più
nessuno se non altro al nord per fortuna
ci sono i funerali per quei funerali
tutti vanno nelle chiese almeno ogni
tanto si va in centro
però fatto sta che i centri dei nostri
paesi mentre le città si sono adeguate e
centri di paesi sono morti i centri dei
paesi sono diventati come dire dei
nostri paesi parliamo del varesotto ma
anche del veneto sono diventato in un
certo senso le periferie delle nuove dei
nuovi paesi che sono andati all'esterno
e allora la storia che vi racconto oggi
negli altri cinque minuti che ho è la
storia di morazzone
forse voi conoscete tutti i paesi
dimostrazione uno dei tanti paesi del
varesotto è un bel paese 8 ma non è non
è castiglione olona un bel paese 8 ma
neanche tanto bello però in tutte le sue
vecchie case non c'è niente di speciale
un bel campanile ci sono due belle ville
signorili però ci vivono soli signori
c'è una bellissima chiesa si vede lì
nell'angolo costruita a sinistra da
simone cantoni un grande architetto e
tardo neoclassico lombardo in questo
paese in quella casa che vedete lei
viveva una signorina piuttosto bizzarra
la quale quando morire i suoi genitori
degli anni cinquanta chiuse casa e non
entrò mai più nella sua casa andava in
giardino ma in caso non è più andata si
vede qualche ricordo non felicissimo
fatto sta che questa casa è rimasta una
specie di pompei dell'ottocento perché
era ancora redatta in tutt ora lo è con
i mobili dai nonni e poi conservato dei
genitori dove tutto è rimasto come
quando i nonni di questa signorina
d'arredo sono tutte le stanze letti le
lenzuola le tovaglie pubblicato come si
legge una volta negli armadi pieni di
cose le vetrine piene dei bicchieri del
rosolio dello champagne del tutti i
servizi di piatti tutte le pentole le
televisioni a schermo piatto profonde
così è un miracolo io non ho mai visto
in vita mia una casa talmente ben
conservata dalla signorina morendo la
lascialfari pregando il fai in eredità
pregando il fai di fare in modo che era
di raccontare ai morazzonesi della loro
storia allora noi siamo abituati di
solito a gestire grandi
come villa panza e mila vogliono dei
pezzi d'italia di costa eccetera però
l'idea di gestire una sorta di racconto
borghese normale come tanti ce ne sono
stati che quello come dire dove hanno
vissuto le persone che hanno fatto
l'italia perché naturalmente il nome
alla garibaldino e poi il nonno e le
bisnonne da cacciatore ha fatto sta cosa
faccio vado al sindaco e ci sono questi
giovani nuovi sindaci che hanno capito
che la morte di centri storici dei
nostri paesi è un dramma e quindi
insieme abbiamo detto io accetto
l'eredità però se tu mi dai una mano
cioè se il progetto è quello di
riportare il rossore sulle gote di
morazzone perché a morazzone non c'è più
un negozio tranne quello che si vede qui
quella cartolibreria edicola
e poi c'è un ristorantino ma noi
restaurando la casa e riportandola al
suo originario splendore che poi è
quello lì non bisogna toccare niente
visitatori solamente togliere questa
ragnatele gigantesche che sembrano
tessute nei cotonifici di busto arsizio
dell'ottocento è una cosa da pazzi
perché nessuno e mai più entrato per 80
anni in quella casa è anche un giardino
incantevole con le palme la peschiera la
moglie era un sogno allora la gente
forse demon azione tornerà in centro a
vedere e dirà a te se ne ricordi la mia
nonna l'aveva anche a lei lei stessa non
parlo inglese va un pochino dialetto va
bene pazienza allora e questo forse darà
i morazzonesi il motivo di ricordare che
anche loro ma poi noi porteremo anche 20
25 30 mila visitatori l'anno a morazzone
che dovranno di che dovranno girare per
il paese allora il ristorante e farà più
farà più coperti e allora il record raio
magari venderà più quaderni e poi ecco e
poi apriranno forse di nuovi negozi
apriranno dei negozi di artigiani li
fanno del buon vino e quindi venderanno
il vino cioè il centro storico forse
tornerà allora perché dobbiamo tornare a
credere nei centri storici dei nostri
paesi e dobbiamo evitare questa
tristezza che sono diventati le
periferie di loro stessi e perché nel
centro storico c'è la nostra memoria
sono nati i genitori sono amati nonni
sono
bisnonni ci sono le storie che uniscono
i cittadini di morazzone i cittadini di
azzate i cittadini di caronno pertusella
i cittadini gavirate uno è un buon
cittadino del mondo se un buon cittadino
d'europa se un buon cittadino d'italia
ma se un buon cittadino del suo paese se
forte delle sue tradizioni si è forte
dei suoi ricordi se sa anche intessere
con ha detto papà francesco dei delle
relazioni che oggi purtroppo in quel
marmellata di paesi non si hanno più una
volta tutti si conoscevano in paese sono
bambini andava dal cartolaio diceva
compro luoghi giugno un quaderno poi
passa la mamma ma certo roberto e poi si
giocava in piazza roberto a dormire no
perché giovanni sta ancora stato guardo
donna va bene si parlava tutto così
e cioè era una relazione fatta di voci i
volti non era una relazione via web
ecco io penso che se noi torniamo a
credere nei centri storici e dei nostri
paesi torniamo a credere in noi stessi
siamo più forti ci abituiamo a ricreare
quelle relazioni che ci aiuteranno ad
essere dei cittadini più consapevoli
perché forti della storia non soltanto
dell'italia non soltanto della lombardia
del veneto ma forti della piccola
fondamentale storia del paese nel quale
siamo nati
[Applauso]